hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game that will make your
head spin yeah it's from 1995 it was
played in Amsterdam and it's a game
between unit Polgar and Alexei shirov uh
one of the greatest attackers against
one of the greatest attackers and uh
Europe was some 18 years old at the time
this game was placed here with some 22
his four years uh older than unit and
okay it was uh there was uh quite a
difference in raiding but not all that
much if you uh for example if you check
here uh shirov is number seven in the
world okay the game was played in August
this is a rating with from July because
back then uh you didn't have a new
rating list every month I think it was
uh every three months uh so Shiro was
rated number seven and the unit was
rated number 27 in the world
interestingly you can see that under
title everyone is listed as G uh meaning
Grandmaster and she's listed as uh WG
sort of woman Grand Master even though
she does have her Grand Master title
um all the way from 1991. uh she got it
very very early even uh beaten Bobby
Fischer's record to do it uh but okay
I'm sure fide has a good reason for that
uh but getting back to the game uh truly
a spectacular one uh let's enjoy it and
then we're going to discuss stuff as we
usually do so udit has the white pieces
and she opens with Ponte E4 shirov goes
for G6 uh this is the modern defense
something for example Magnus Carlsen
plays nowadays and he has very good
results with it the D4 with Bishop to G7
uh and now Knight to C3 uh we have uh
Pawn to C6 by shirov and now Bishop to
C4 and just uh going for Rapid peace
development D6 and now Queen to F3 you
did already threatening Queen captures
on F7 so E6 and now Knight to G to E2 we
have B5 by Shiro Bishop to B3 and A5 and
this is pretty much uh uh even by modern
standards uh a a top top level game uh
there are many games with the this exact
set of moves being played even in let's
say 2021 so A3 not allowing shirov to
trap the bishop and now Bishop to A6 uh
we have D5 now you could consider a lot
of things here
uh you don't have to go for D5 you could
go for E5 you could go for H4 you could
uh just try and play it safe but shirov
basically wants to have constant
pressure along this diagonal he wants to
have the option of playing B4 he wants
to put the knights on D7 and D7 and have
a very very flexible setup um uh so so
if you it might uh tend to be a little
bit over aggressive he could go for some
sort of a counter attack but uh okay
that's a very good plan but you have to
be very very precise in doing that
because you know that unit will will
come for you so she goes Pawn to D5 and
okay nothing spectacular Happening Here
C captures e captures and shirov closes
the central with Pawn to E5 she goes
Knight to E4 uh improves the the
position of the Knight and now we have
Queen to C7 nowadays uh it is known that
H6 uh really should be played here for
very good reasons and you will see those
reasons as we go deeper into the game
Queen to C7 and now uh you could
consider something like Bishop to D2
here you could consider H4 uh but
usually goes for the immediate C4 and it
is now as of move 12 that this position
has never been reached again and uh you
know from a perspective of 1995 we have
a completely new game and okay uh shirov
says that's a free Pawn let's grab it uh
B captures on C4 it's the absolute best
move you you really should capture this
Pawn so see captures on B5 uh B captures
on C4 now Bishop to a for with check uh
and okay Knight to D7 and now Knight to
the C3 uh preventing this Pawn from ever
being pushed forward
um as long as this Pawn is on C4 it
protects you from the bishop and from
the queen on the C file and from the
potential rook and the C file so even
though uh black one upon here that pawn
isn't really doing all that much for
black at the moment and the problem is
how do you continue developing uh this
is the problem position of this game and
it's uh it's very hard to find the move
for black of course you cannot play
Knight to F6 if you just try to develop
a knight captures and F6 check wins the
game okay the Knight on D7 is pinned
you've just blunder the piece if you go
instead of night the F6 if you go Knight
to E7 it's not much better look at this
bishop captures on D7
uh Queen captures and now Bishop to H6
trying to get the bishop away from the
defense of the F6 Square so you can Fork
the king and the Queen and now okay you
can just castle of course you're not
gonna fall for that but now let's say
Captain's captures Queen to F6 check
King to Jade and not Knight captures on
D6 uh unit would regain the pawn and be
left with the spectacular past the D
Pawn let's say if Knight to F5 you can
just move the Knight back in ID to e for
then the pawn is coming to D6 The Rook
will support the pawn and this Pawn will
forever haunt black
um and especially the the light Square
version so not really an option so you
can go Knight to F6 you can't go Knight
to E7 is there anything else you could
play
it's it's a very hard to uh like really
really difficult to find the move here
the move you should play here is either
Rook to B8 but that's a weird move to
play so let's let's say H6 h60 is the
top engine move and it uh uh well it
seems seems like it solves all of
White's problems but you have to see
like you really have to see the future
in order to play this move because look
at this now Knight captures on D6 check
Queen captures on D6 Knights the E4
attacks the queen and now what do you do
if you play Queen captures on D5 then
Bishop to E3 and after Rook to D1 you
can just resign here there is no
defending this position so you can't
really capture the pawn you would have
to move the queen queen to C7 and now
look at this Pawn to D6 and now what do
you play uh you have to move the queen
somewhere let's say queen to C8 now
comes the bishop captures on D7 Queen
captures and now the spectacular Knight
the C5 move attacks the black queen the
rook and A8 is hanging also the bishop
is attacked if the queen moves even Pawn
to D7 check is an option and uh it seems
like you can just resign here as black
but this is exactly everything move by
move what you had to do in order to
survive that position but in order to do
all of this you had to find Bishop to B7
from that position where you played H6
so okay and maybe asking a bit too much
a point is now the black the White Queen
is also attacked and after Knight
captures on B7 now you play Knight to F6
and you try to Castle to safety if
Knight the C5 attacking the queen
finally you have E4 here I mean uh who
who sees stuff like that Queen F4 Queen
to F5 you offer a queen crate and okay
now the game continues to even have nice
control over the D7 square with your
king and the Knight here so that's what
you should play here so you can play
Knight to F6 you can play Knights the E7
you definitely should play H6 or the
weird Rook to B8 move but shirov says
I'm gonna uh skip all of that I'm just
gonna play King to E7 now this unpins
the king from the bishop but it runs
into a different kind of um a situation
so feel free to pause the video for the
first time uh and try to find the only
winning move for you while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
Knight captures on D6 uh Works in this
position as well but for very different
reasons and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
Knight captures and D6 and the reason
for that is look at this now Queen
captures on D6 you have to play this and
not Knight the E4 and now the difference
is uh after Queen captures on D5 there
is no more Bishop to E3 followed by Rook
to D1 because now if you go for Bishop
to E3 just Knight to F6 and you don't
have to worry about anything uh because
the the Knight on D7 is no longer pinned
so you don't have Knight captures on F6
check uh it would be check if the King
was an E8 and here the black queen would
be lost so that also one of the reasons
why I should have moved the king to E7
to be able to play this but udit finds a
different uh killing uh maneuver and
that's uh Bishop to G5 with check and
now what do you play Knight D to F6 was
played uh not not much else you can try
here and now again and feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
winning idea for you to while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook a to D1 uh whenever you uh try to
analyze the position in The Rook a to D1
is possible always think it's Rook a to
D1 always you know think of uh think of
Anderson's Evergreen game like if
Anderson didn't think of Rook 8 to D1 we
would not have the Evergreen game so I
always think of Rook 8 to D1 and now the
problem is what do you do with the queen
here is there a move you can try here of
course this check is impossible you can
just pick up the queen and the Knight
cannot move so you have to move the
queen somewhere let's say you try to
move the queen somewhere weird let's say
queen to E6 the problem here is that
Rook the D7 check works whatever black
plays and now okay you don't have to
give up the queen just yes yet King f8
now Knight the C5 attacks the queen and
after Queen to E8 now look at this Rook
captures an F7 with check and now this
again becomes a problem what you play
here if you capture with the King then
of course just Bishop captures Queen so
you have to capture with the queen now
comes with a queen captures the root can
A8 uh King to E7 and queen to A7 with
check King to f8 and now Queen to B8
with check and finally after you block
this now comes Knight to D7 check and
the black king has no more squares you
have to give up your queen so after Rook
to D1 uh okay I should have said let's
go back but Queen to B7 but now again
this runs into Rook to D7 with check the
Knight is still pinned and should have
must part with his Queen so Queen
captures on D7 Bishop captures on D7 and
now Pawn to H6 trying to get this bishop
away from pinning the Knight so you can
recapture here uh and uh yeah I mean you
don't have to play this you could also
play King captures on D7
uh but it's not really spectacular we're
just gonna play Knight to C5 check and
pick up the Rook on A8 once again so
after Bishop captures on D7 shirov does
play H6 uh some five moves too late and
now uh there are plenty of ways you can
uh continue this game but Judith finds
the absolute uh strongest move uh Queen
to D1 and it was in this position on
move 21 that Alexa should have resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here there is uh there's really
something spectacular in finishing uh uh
such a brutal attacking game by bringing
your queen back to the starting square
and your opponent is just helpless uh
because uh now okay let's say you
capture the bishop H captors on G5 uh
just Queen D6 check and what do you what
do you play you have to go behind the
bishop now a nice Discovery here Bishop
B5 checking the C8 Queen to C6 checking
to B8 and now Queen to B6 with check
will force a nice um a Checkmate
regardless of what your playlist and
knights the D6 Checkmate and if you
don't capture the bishop what else is
there to do you could try running away
with the King but not just Queen to D6
with check regardless of what you do uh
there's just no saving this position
Knight to E7 but now you know you no
longer have control over the F6 Square
so Bishop captures Bishop captures Queen
captures The Rook is hanging Rook to H7
and now Queen captures an E5 and you
have zero compensation for uh you you're
not having a queen because look at this
they both have a knight they both have a
bishop they both have a rook and uh unit
has a queen for a full Rook here but
this Rook isn't even present in the game
so it would be completely pointless to
continue this so after Queen to D1
Beautiful Finish
uh in 21 moves uh by uh by 18 year old
uh Judith pogar uh who also not only won
this game but did incredibly well uh in
the tournament that these are the final
standings of the tournament you can see
that uh she was only behind half a point
behind uh Julio Tunica and Ian timan who
finished the first uh tied first uh with
seven and a half points and she was
clear third with seven points ahead of
some uh incredibly strong chess players
like Yasir cerevan who's manchirovich
salov John noon uh khalifman Pickett and
Lok van Valley uh John noon uh even uh
placed this game in his uh famous book
about brilliances I don't know the exact
name of the book but it's like a 135
incredible chess brilliances and this
game made it to his book and if you are
familiar with the John noon or John Nunn
uh you know that you know that's not an
easy list to make uh so yeah absolutely
an incredible game hope you guys enjoyed
it and I mean in in that position after
this Knight to the C3 was played uh
finding finding this uh H6 idea and all
of those moves are finding Bishop to B7
and then E4 I mean uh I mean surviving
this uh as you can see was uh not
possible even even for you know a true
Master of the Mystic Arts like Alexa
shirov uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I I mean I I was
so impressed by this game I I I don't
know how uh this is the first time I'm
seeing it so I'm very glad to be able to
present it to you as I imagine some of
you are seeing it for the first time as
well but what an attacking Masterpiece
uh but yeah even though eurith was some
27th ranked in the world at the time uh
uh she she got the I think in 2004 uh to
being the uh eighth number eight in the
world which is absolutely incredible
she's the only woman ever to cross the
2700 rating threshold to some 2735 I
believe and uh okay fun was fairly close
I think she was 26 86 so very close to
2700 but that was also back in 2015 uh
so we'll see what uh what the future
brings who will be the next woman to hit
that 2700 Mark uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed the brilliant
attacking masterpiece I would like to
thank WWE dww Simon Johnson ravishing
reptiles YouTube Francisco and
randompile.net for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World the Tata still is
starting tomorrow uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day